- Just hold the car seat steady.
- All right.
One step at a time.
Let me know if you need anything.
- Yeah.
(cheerful music)
(groans)
- She kinda looks like you.
- She kinda looks like a raisin.
Honey, can you help me up?
Oh, they don't tell you
how painful this is.
- You smell like you've had
some things happen downstairs.
Let's get to the bottom of that, okay?
Oh, wow!
That's everywhere.
(laughs)
That is--
- Here you go.
- You see this? It's a lot.
- You're going to need that, actually.
I can't do this.
I'm going to ruin her life.
- Honey, it's just a diaper rash.
- I can't even change a diaper right!
- Honey, I need help.
Can you get my phone?
- I'm gonna go get more diapers.
- [Woman] You're in a robe.
- It's alright.
(baby crying)
- Let me see,
I can take the baby and you can lay down.
Okay?
No problem, okay.
You're alright.
It's been some time.
I was thinking maybe you might wanna--
- No.
- Wow, that's your biggest blowout yet!
It's very impressive.
She is finally asleep.
- I really miss her.
- Yeah, me too.
- It's been a crazy month.
- Yeah, but it's the best kind of crazy.
(cheerful music)
(snoring)
- I don't know how I'm gonna get up.